Bene, buonasera.
Bene, grazie.
Bene.
grazie.
Bene, grazie.
riferiscono solo al fatto che per i cristiani del Medioevo il problema di quando arriverà
la fine del mondo fosse un problema sentito. Quello non è in discussione. Quando si parla
dei terrori dell'anno 1000 ci si riferisce proprio a un'immagine ben precisa, all'idea
cioè che nel Medioevo pensavano che il mondo sarebbe finito nell'anno 1000 e quindi quando
l'anno 1000 ha cominciato a avvicinarsi, perché voi capite che queste cose finché le dici
nell'anno 750, ma quando l'anno 1000 ha cominciato a avvicinarsi, secondo questo racconto la gente
ha cominciato a aver paura sul serio e negli ultimi anni prima dell'anno 1000 il mondo si
è quasi fermato, non aveva più senso mettersi e darsi da fare, fondare una famiglia, lavorare,
tanto il mondo finisce fra tre anni, fra due, l'anno prossimo finisce e negli ultimi mesi
dell'anno 999 il mondo si è davvero fermato, secondo questa storia che troviamo raccontata
da tanti studiosi, da tanti dotti della nostra epoca dell'800, del 900 ancora. Negli ultimi
mesi dell'anno 999 la gente si affollava nelle chiese a pregare e piangere sperando di salvarsi
perché appena fosse finito l'anno 999 finiva il mondo. Ecco io adesso ve l'ho detta con parole
mie, ma in realtà vorrei ricordare quanto profondamente era sentito questo tema, in particolare
nella cultura dell'800 e che impatto romantico aveva questa immagine di un intero mondo piegato
dal terrore perché aspetta la fine del mondo. Vi leggo poche righe di un brano del
Carducci. Carducci scrive questo nel primo dei suoi discorsi sullo svolgimento della letteratura
nazionale. È una storia della letteratura italiana, perché Carducci si preoccupa dei
terrore dell'anno 1000. Ne parleremo. Intanto sentiamo Carducci che era uno che sapeva scrivere
«Vi immaginate il levar del sole nel primo giorno dell'anno 1000? Questo fatto di tutte
le mattine ricordate che fu quasi miracolo? Fu promessa di vita nuova per le generazioni
uscenti dal secolo X». E poi dice Carducci i terrori che si erano accumulati per anni
e anni e naturalmente anche le ragioni di aver paura, le epidemie, le carestie, i prodigi,
tutto questo all'avvicinarsi dell'anno 1000 si coagula in un'immensa paura collettiva.
Sempre Carducci. Mille e non più mille. Aveva, secondo la tradizione, detto Gesù. Dopo
mille anni, leggevasi nell'Apocalipsi, Satana sarà disciolto. Dopodiché segue appunto la
descrizione delle folle gementi nelle chiese negli ultimi giorni dell'anno 1000, del 999,
e poi c'è lo straordinario colpo di scena. Il primo giorno dell'anno 1000 il sole sorge
e non è successo niente. E che stupore di gioia e che grido salì al cielo dalle turbe
raccolte in gruppi silenziosi intorno a manieri feudali, accosciate e singhiozzanti nelle chiese
tenebrose e nei chiostri, quando il sole, eterno fonte di luce e di vita, si levò trionfale
la mattina dell'anno 1000. Formidabile, naturalmente. Carducci è un grande scrittore, ma queste
cose le scrivevano anche i miei colleghi, gli storici, nell'Ottocento. Giusto per non
negarci niente, due righe da uno storico francese, il Lavallè, allievo di Michelet.
Storia dei francesi, 1844. Traduco alla buona. La credenza nella fine del mondo, credenza
che sembrava giustificata dalle pesti, le fami, le calamità di ogni genere che desolavano
l'Europa, provocava una atonia universale. Tutto era ghiacciato di paura nell'attesa del
giorno fatale. Ogni impresa si era fermata, ogni movimento si era arrestato, non c'era
più né speranza né avvenire. Si raddoppiava di fervore religioso, con gioia del professor
Odifreddi che vedo qui davanti a me. Ci si accumulava, ci si affollava nei conventi, si
donavano i propri beni alla chiesa e da ogni parte si sentiva questo grido lugubre. La fine
del mondo si avvicina. Bene, abbiamo assodato se non altro un punto. Nell'ottocento erano
tutti convinti che ci fosse stato questo terrore collettivo che ha bloccato la società europea.
Abbiamo modo di controllare, abbiamo modo di andare a vedere cosa succedeva davvero nell'anno
novecentonovantanove. Con un po' di fatica sì. Andiamo a cercare dei documenti scritti
in quell'anno. Per esempio, cosa faceva il Papa alla fine del novecentonovantanove? Papa
che doveva essere abbastanza interessato all'argomento evidentemente. Noi abbiamo una bolla
papale, pensate che fortuna, del trentun dicembre novecentonovantanove. Il trentun dicembre
novecentonovantanove Papa Silvestro II conferma i privilegi di un grande monastero tedesco,
il monastero di Fulda. Sono vari privilegi che la sede romana conferma su richiesta dell'abate
e il Papa consegna questa bolla datata trentun dicembre novecentonovantanove all'abate di Fulda
dicendogli ti confermo tutti i privilegi del tuo monastero a te e ai tuoi successori a patto
che in futuro ogni abate che verrà eletto venga a chiedere a Roma la conferma della sua elezione.
inoltre voi in cambio di questi privilegi monaci di Fulda dovete pagare un'offerta ogni
anno di dodici denari alla sede romana da pagare in futuro ogni anno. Almeno questi due
non si stavano aspettando la fine del mondo evidentemente. È vero che Papa Silvestro II era
un personaggio speciale, era un grande erudito, un grande dotto, tanto dotto che qualcuno addirittura
lo sospettava anche di un po' di intrallazzi con la magia, si chiamava Gerberto di Oriac prima
di diventare Papa. Magari lui era uno un po' speciale, magari gli sprovveduti e la gente
qualunque invece se l'aspettavano questa fine del mondo. Andiamo a vedere cosa faceva la gente
qualunque nel novecentonovantanove. Tra un po' di documenti che ho trovato ve ne cito uno
a caso, ho cercato fra quelli piemontesi che per me era più comodo. Siamo a Tortona, in un
mese imprecisato del novecentonovantanove. Due fratelli, uno è un prete, Adelberto, l'altro
è un laico e Renzone, sono due piccoli imprenditori, prendono in affitto delle case e delle terre
e dei campi dal monastero di San Marziano di Tortona. Prendono in affitto queste terre
con un contratto scritto, cosa che nell'anno novecentonovantanove in certe parti d'Europa
non si usava più tanto, perché in molte parti di Europa andavano più alla buona. Un
contratto, uno sputo sul palmo, stretta di mano. In Italia, il paese più vicino alle
sue radici classiche, si usava di più andare dal notaio, anche per fare un contratto d'affitto.
Facevano questo contratto d'affitto che chiamavano il libretto, libellus in latino. Questo contratto
d'affitto noi ce l'abbiamo. L'abate dà in affitto queste terre a questi due fratelli
per la durata di, qui vi voglio preparare, nelle nostre campagne fino a un po' di tempo
fa era in vigore la mezzadria e la mezzadria voi sapete che era un sistema in apparenza
paritario, in realtà molto squilibrato a favore del padrone e normalmente il contratto durava
un anno. Alla fine del raccolto a San Martino il mezzadro consegnava tutto e se il padrone
voleva cacciarlo lo poteva cacciare. L'albero degli zoccoli di Armando Olmi, tanto per citare
un film che magari molti hanno visto. Nel Medioevo non era così. Nel Medioevo c'erano
poche braccia e uno dei grandi problemi per un proprietario terriero, tanto più per i monaci
che avevano altro a cui pensare che non star sempre dietro ai campi, un grande problema
per i proprietari terrieri era di trovare lavoratori che stessero lì, anzi semmai di
costringerli a stare lì se possibile, anziché cacciarli. Quindi nel Medioevo usavano contratti
a lunga scadenza. Nell'anno 999 l'abate di San Marziano di Tortona dà in affitto queste
terre del monastero a questi due fratelli per la durata di 29 anni, a condizione che dovranno
abitarci, coltivarle, non permettere che queste terre vadano in malora e ogni anno
pagheranno al monastero un terzo del grano raccolto e metà del vino. Non solo fa comodo
al padrone averli lì per 29 anni, ma anche a loro fa comodo, è una bella garanzia per
il contadino. Dunque la garanzia sta a contratto. Vi diamo queste terre per 29 anni. Se nell'arco
di questi 29 anni qualche mio successore abate dovesse cercare di riprendersele pagherà
la penale di 20 soldi d'argento prevista dal contratto. Dunque anche questi nell'anno
999 non si aspettavano che il mondo finisse l'anno dopo evidentemente. Non c'è proprio
nessuno che parla della fine del mondo nell'anno 999. Alla fine un documento l'ho trovato che
parla della fine del mondo, ma bisogna vedere in che termini. È un diploma dell'imperatore
Ottone III. L'imperatore Ottone III quell'anno è andato a Roma per varie brighe sue. Arriva
a Roma e naturalmente si affolla la gente che gli chiede, si affollano i postulanti che
gli chiedono donazioni, conferme, diplomi, benefici e così via. Tra l'altro arrivano
i monaci di Farfa. Farfa è un grande monastero laziale. Anche loro hanno dei privilegi naturalmente.
Farfa è un grande monastero imperiale, appartiene all'imperatore, però loro hanno un privilegio
che l'imperatore non lo può regalare a qualcun altro quel monastero. Come invece gli imperatori
facevano volentieri? Hai un vecchio consigliere da premiare che deve andare in pensione, un
tipo importante. Cosa ne fai? Lo nomini abate di un monastero che va da lì e si goda le ricchezze
di quel monastero. Queste cose ai monaci piacciono poco. I monaci di Farfa hanno il privilegio,
non possono essere dati in questo modo a nessuno. Il loro abate se lo eleggono loro. L'imperatore
Ottone III dice benissimo, siamo d'accordo, ve lo concediamo. Confermiamo questo privilegio,
dice l'imperatore, il 3 ottobre 999. Traduco dal latino. Per cui d'ora in poi, in eterno,
mai più nessuno dei nostri successori potrà dare in beneficio a qualcuno il monastero di
Farfa, ma rimanga sempre di proprietà dello Stato. Res pubblica.
Se qualche Papa in futuro o qualche imperatore nostro successore dovesse invece soggiogare
quel monastero a qualcuno, si ricordi che quando poi verrà Cristo e tutti quanti dovremo rendergli
i nostri conti, dovrà rispondere di aver infranto la mia promessa. Perché Cristo verrà,
la fine del mondo ci sarà e tutti dovremo rendere i conti prima o poi. Ma chiaramente
anche l'imperatore non si aspettava che l'anno finisse l'anno dopo, che il mondo finisse
l'anno dopo.
C'è un altro modo di controllare? Beh sì. C'erano dei cronisti all'epoca, certo
che c'erano. Persone, di solito studiosi e quindi di solito all'epoca uomini di chiesa,
monaci, che a un bel momento decidevano di mettersi a tavolino e scrivere i grandi avvenimenti
a cui assistevano. Magari anche solo poche righe, magari invece anche di più, anno per
anno. Ci sono parecchi cronisti che hanno vissuto l'anno 1000 e che scrivono, nel 998
è successo questo e quell'altro, nel 99 è successo questo, nel 1000 è successo quest'altro,
l'imperatore è andato a Roma, nel 1001 è tornato in Germania e così via. Non c'è
nessuno che dica c'era il terrore dell'anno 1000, c'erano le folle, c'erano dei movimenti,
penite niente. Dobbiamo pensare che nel Medioevo erano gente così laica e disinvolta, che della
fine del mondo non gli importava niente? No, evidentemente, l'abbiamo appena visto, della
fine del mondo gli importava. Il problema è quando verrà la fine del mondo. C'è modo
di saperlo. Torniamo un po' indietro. Noi l'abbiamo detto, il Carducci dice mille, non
più mille, ha citato l'Apocalisse. Ecco, andiamo un po' a vedere. Cosa ne sapevano loro della
fine del mondo? Sapevano tutto, tranne la data. Sapevano tutto perché c'è il libro
dell'Apocalisse che descrive esattamente come avverrà la fine del mondo. Il libro
dell'Apocalisse che è l'ultimo libro canonico del Nuovo Testamento, attribuito a San Giovanni
Evangelista ma probabilmente non è vero, comunque testo antico, fine primo secolo, un testo totalmente
delirante, va detto, visionario, che racconta le cose più straordinarie e che complessivamente
si presenta come la descrizione della fine del mondo. Questa cosa per gli ecclesiastici
del Medioevo era molto importante e molto utile anche. Immaginate un cronista che vuole
scrivere la storia universale. Va in biblioteca, comincia, trova gli storici antichi, i greci,
i romani, i cartaginesi, Annibale e così via, Costantino il grande imperatore cristiano,
i barbari, Carlo Magno. Poi siamo arrivati adesso al presente, lascio un po' di pagine
bianche e poi volendo la parte finale la posso già mettere perché si sa già come sarà
la fine del mondo. Basta andare a prendere l'Apocalisse e la descrive. Verrà l'anticristo,
commetterà ogni sorta di nefandezze, poi verrà sconfitto, tornerà Cristo. L'Apocalisse,
come vi dicevo, è un testo visionario e farraginoso dove si trova di tutto. A un certo punto
l'autore dell'Apocalisse comincia a giocare col numero mille. Non si capisce niente e non
è che mi dovete credere, adesso ve lo leggo, ma che c'entri l'anno mille o meglio il numero
mille, questo è evidente. Apocalisse 20, versetti 1, 7.
Poi vidi un angelo che scendeva dal cielo e che aveva la chiave dell'abisso e una gran
catena in mano. Egli prese il dragone, il serpente antico, che è il diavolo e Satana,
e lo legò per mille anni. Poi lo gettò nell'abisso che chiuse e sigillò sopra di lui,
perché non seducesse più le nazioni finché fossero compiuti i mille anni. Uno legge questo
e dice cosa vorrà dire? Sembrerebbe dire che a un certo punto per mille anni Satana è
reso impotente, perché? Perché è venuto Cristo, certo, saranno mille anni da quando
è venuto Cristo. E poi però allora qua dice che dopo mille anni lo liberano Satana e
subito dopo verrà la fine del mondo. Questa è una linea di ragionamento che è possibile.
È talmente possibile, se mi permettete una piccola parentesi, che anche oggi, perché
non è che noi oggi ne sappiamo di più che nel Medioevo, anche oggi salta fuori ogni
tanto la setta, è vero che succede più facilmente nel Texas protestante che non qui da noi, ma
anche oggi salta fuori ogni tanto la setta che dice guardate che verrà la fine del mondo
e tutti gli adepti donano tutti i loro beni al capo della setta e poi a volte si suicidano
anche tutti quanti insieme. Ecco, questi movimenti, queste sette, noi come li chiamiamo? Li chiamiamo
movimenti millenaristi. Parliamo di sette millenariste, di millenarismo, quando ci riferiamo
a qualcuno che predica l'avvicinarsi della fine del mondo. Parliamo di millenarismo perché
continuiamo a essere impregnati di queste cose che si leggono nell'Apocalisse, che accosta
i mille anni alla fine del mondo.
E dunque, all'avvicinarsi dell'anno mille, c'è stato qualcuno, abbiamo appena visto
che nel 999 non ci pensavano più, si era messi il cuore in pace, ma in quei decenni c'è
stato qualcuno che ha fatto questi ragionamenti sul libro dell'Apocalisse e che ha cominciato
a dire in giro preparatevi perché guardate che nell'anno mille il mondo finisce. C'è stato
qualcuno? Sì. Noi abbiamo un racconto preciso. Chi racconta è un monaco, tanto per cambiare,
in quest'epoca quasi tutti quelli che hanno voglia di raccontare storie sono monaci. Si
chiama Abbone, abate di Fleury in Francia. Abbone di Fleury, grande studioso, grande scrittore,
grande intellettuale, uno che ha letto molto e capisce molto, scrive un libretto nell'anno
998, dedicato al re di Francia Roberto. Abbone di Fleury dice al re di Francia, guarda
che nel tuo regno ci sono parecchie cose che non vanno, ci sono parecchie cose che andrebbero
corrette. Non sta parlando del fatto che i conti, anziché rendere giustizia, intascano
Bustarelle. Non è di quello che parla, parla delle credenze, della cultura, di come funziona
la Chiesa. Dice guarda che nel tuo regno ci sono molti errori che vanno corretti. Per
esempio ci sono dei chierici che non sanno bene il credo e quando recitano il credo
sbagliano. Dovrebbero dire lo Spirito Santo procede dal padre e dal figlio, invece dicono
procede dal padre, dimenticano il figlio. Questo non va mica bene, va corretto. Ci sono
dei chierici che fanno degli sbagli nel calcolare il calendario liturgico, fanno cominciare l'avvento
un giorno prima e anche questo non va bene, dice Abbone, il re deve provvedere. E poi
dice Abbone, nel tuo regno in passato, adesso è un po' che non succede, siamo nel 998, ma
in passato ogni tanto venivano fuori queste storie della fine del mondo e bisognava darsi
un grande affare per tranquillizzare la gente. Abbone dice, io mi ricordo quando ero
un ragazzino, e si calcola che siamo intorno al 970, quando ero un ragazzino io stesso ho
sentito a Parigi, in una chiesa di Parigi, un predicatore che avvertiva che nell'anno
1000 sarebbe venuta la fine del mondo. E io, dice Abbone, che già da ragazzino era uno
che aveva studiato, io allora mi ricordo che mi sono sforzato di farlo star zitto e di
spiegare a tutti che si sbagliava citando l'Apocalisse e il libro di Daniele e il Vangelo
e così via. Poi, dice Abbone, è venuto fuori quell'altro
sbaglio sulla fine del mondo. Mi ricordo che ai tempi del buon Abate Riccardo, e siamo
sempre intorno al 970 più o meno, sono arrivate al nostro monastero delle lettere che dicevano
che in Lorena c'era qualcuno che aveva fatto questo calcolo assurdo, aveva detto, io vi chiedo
scusa se vi trascino in queste cose complesse, ma questa gente viveva di questi ragionamenti
e di queste sottigliezze. Qualcuno aveva detto, l'anno in cui il venerdì santo coinciderà
con l'annunciazione, cioè il 25 marzo, ci sarà la fine del mondo. Se ci ragioniamo
un attimo, perché questo? È chiaro, in quell'anno si chiude un circolo, l'annunciazione è l'arrivo
di Gesù, che è ovviamente l'evento più grande della storia del mondo, la venuta di
Gesù, ai loro occhi. Il venerdì santo è la morte di Gesù. Se un anno, le due date
coincidono, siccome noi esseri umani siamo in grado di metterci in testa le cose più
folli e di crederci, intorno al 970 c'era qualcuno che andava in giro dicendo, guardate
che, ovviamente io sono andato a vedere sul calendario perpetuo, quando è che c'era
stata l'ultima volta questa coincidenza? Nel 908, era passato un bel po' di tempo,
quando c'è stata di nuovo questa coincidenza del venerdì santo con l'annunciazione? Nel
970, guarda lì, si vede che l'anno prima qualcuno ha fatto quel calcolo, ma la cosa interessante
è che Abbone, che ci sta raccontando questa cosa, dice, quando è arrivata questa notizia
il buon abate Riccardo mi ha detto, Abbone, occupatene tu, scrivi tu in Lorena per spiegare
che queste sono tutte fregnacce. Non si esprime così tecnicamente, ma è chiaro che questo
è il senso del discorso. E io, dice Abbone, ho scritto spiegando quanto fosse folle questo
ragionamento. Ergo, facciamo il punto, è assodato che l'idea della fine del mondo che
arriva ogni tanto girava e che anche associarla con l'anno mille non era affatto impossibile,
a qualcuno è venuto in mente. Quello che è assodato è che queste cose ogni tanto venivano
fuori e che venivano immediatamente messe a tacere. Non avevano nessuna possibilità
di espandersi e di circolare perché i pastori provvedevano immediatamente a fermare questi
ragionamenti. E nell'anno 998, quando scrive Abbone, sono ricordi di giovinezza. Ma perché
l'abate Riccardo dice ad Abbone queste sono tutte frottole, scrivi tu, perché sono così
convinti gli uomini di chiesa che non funzionano questi calcoli, che è sbagliato cercare di
prevedere quando verrà la fine del mondo. Ecco, il punto è proprio questo. Non è che
i calcoli non funzionano, è che gli uomini di chiesa del Medioevo sanno che è sbagliato
cercare di prevedere la fine del mondo. Ed è sbagliato, è giudizio universale naturalmente,
è sbagliato perché sta scritto nella Bibbia che non si può sapere. Matteo 24, 36. Quanto
a quel giorno e a quell'ora però nessuno lo sa. San Paolo, prima lettera ai testalonicesi.
Il giorno del Signore verrà come viene un ladro nella notte. Cioè non è che si annuncia
prima. Arriva quando non lo sai. Quando diranno, sempre San Paolo, pace e sicurezza,
allora all'improvviso li colpirà la rovina. Ergo, il Signore lo ha detto chiaramente, io
verrò ma voi non potete sapere quando, anzi verrò quando meno ve lo aspettate. Quel giorno
e quell'ora nessuno lo sa. E quindi è perfettamente inutile mettersi a ragionare su queste cose.
Il primo che lo dice chiaramente è un pensatore cristiano dei primi tempi che avrà un'influenza
enorme sul pensiero cristiano medievale e cioè Sant'Agostino. Sant'Agostino ci ragiona
su e lo scrive molto chiaramente. Calcolare i tempi per sapere quando sarà la fine di
questo mondo o l'avvento del Signore mi sembra nient'altro che voler sapere qualcosa che lui
stesso, il Signore, ha detto che nessuno può sapere. Poi fra parentesi c'è anche un altro
piccolo ragionamento che Sant'Agostino, che conosce i suoi testi, tira fuori subito.
Sta scritto anche, dice perché non sappiamo quando viene ma magari viene l'anno prossimo.
Calma. Sta scritto che prima che venga l'anticristo e poi la fine del mondo il Vangelo dovrà essere
predicato a tutti i popoli della Terra. È stato già predicato? No. Perciò non sarà per l'anno
prossimo. Dunque, facciamo anche qui il punto. Siamo arrivati a dire che tensioni millenaristiche,
preoccupazioni per la fine del mondo, nell'arco del Medioevo di tanto in tanto vengono fuori,
ma non hanno spazio per allargarsi, perché dall'alto non sono accettate. E ve ne faccio
un esempio, tanto per farvi vedere come queste cose in realtà capitavano anche spesso, ma
come fossero poi circoscritte. Vi faccio un esempio parecchio prima dell'anno 1000, torniamo
indietro. 847. Siamo nell'anno 847. In Germania un analista racconta che a Magonza è saltata
fuori una donna che sostiene di prevedere il futuro, una pseudoprofetissa, si chiama
Fiota. Questa donna sostiene di conoscere la data della fine del mondo. E guarda caso
sarà l'anno prossimo. Lei conosce questa cosa, dice il monaco, che nessuno può sapere, come
se fosse Dio che gliel'ha rivelata. E la gente, anzi non la gente, il monaco usa un termine significativo,
i plebei. Perché queste cose sono soltanto i poveracci che ci possono credere. Però
di poveracci ce n'è tanti. Questa donna va dicendo che lei lo sa, che la fine del mondo
sarà l'anno prossimo. E molti plebei le credono e vanno da lei e le portano dei regali, chiedendole
di pregare per loro. Il vescovo di Magonza si secca un po'. La convoca, la interroga e viene
fuori, almeno la donna, dice che questa cosa gliel'ha suggerita un prete suo amico, dicendole
tu vai in giro a predicare che l'anno prossimo viene la fine del mondo, vedrai la gente quanti
regali ci porta. E infatti è proprio successo così. Il vescovo si consulta con altri vescovi,
decidono a questa una bella bastonatura, non gliela toglie nessuno, la fanno frustare
sulla pubblica piazza e poi fuori dai piedi e che non osi più farsi sentire. E così
viene, come dire, spento il movimento millenaristico di Magonza dell'anno 847. A questo punto,
quanto tempo mi sono già giocato, beh buona parte per nostra fortuna, se voi ricordate
da dove siamo partiti. Noi siamo partiti da gente, e non gente da poco, ma un Carducci,
storici, accreditati e autorevoli del loro tempo, che ci hanno detto che negli ultimi
mesi e giorni prima dell'anno 1000 c'era il terrore collettivo, le chiese piene, insomma
è inutile che ve lo ridicano. Sembrerebbe assodato che quell'immagine è interamente immaginaria,
appunto, è inventata. Non è vero che è successo questo. Allora però voi capite che
si pone allo storico un problema diverso, ma anch'esso abbastanza interessante. Se non
è mai successo, chi è che l'ha inventata questa storia? Chi, quando, perché, come è
possibile, al di là dell'angoscia di scoprire che noi storici possiamo credere e raccontare,
vedo sempre il professore di Freddy che ride sotto i baffi, ma anche voi matematici, secondo
me, certe volte. Comunque, noi storici possiamo, ahimè, convincerci di cose e convincere chi
ci legge, che poi cent'anni dopo si scopre che sono totalmente inventate. E non è piacevole
rendersene conto, dire la verità. Il rimedio è andare a cercare di capire com'è successo,
perché almeno se uno capisce come succedono queste cose, forse si può starci un po' più
attenti, forse. Com'è successa questa storia? Molti studiosi si sono messi a cercare di
ricostruire la genealogia di questa leggenda dei terrori dell'anno 1000. Ed è saltata fuori
proprio una genealogia, nel senso di una serie di autori che si sono uno dopo l'altro copiati
aggiungendo ognuno qualcosina. Il meccanismo è questo. E a volte ci vogliono secoli perché
questo capiti. Io adesso mi sono chiesto a lungo, preparando questa lezione, gli faccio
tutto l'elenco oppure lo abbrevio, ne faccio qualche esempio. Il primo colpevole è un
cronista del Medioevo, un monaco, che scrive intorno al 1100, cent'anni dopo i fatti. E
un bravo cronista si chiama Sigeberto, Sigeberto di Jean Blu, scrive una cronaca, ha letto tanti
libri, ha letto gli analisti dell'anno 1000, i quali delle paure non parlavano per niente.
È vero però che nell'anno 1000 qualche cronista ha menzionato un terremoto. E i terremoti, voi
capite, è un affare serio perché il terremoto è un segnale, vuol dire qualcosa. Poi Sigeberto
legge le sue fonti e scopre che nel 1002 c'è stata una cometa. E anche la cometa è una
cosa seria perché Dio non si prende il disturbo di modificare l'armonia delle stelle se non c'è
un motivo molto preciso, di mandare un avvertimento agli uomini. Sigeberto fa 2 più 2 e già che
c'è semplifica un po'. Terremoto nel 1000, cometa nel 1002. Sigeberto dice, senti,
qui c'è di mezzo il 1000 evidentemente, quell'anno era un anno un po' speciale. Sigeberto
semplifica. Nell'anno 1000 ci sono stati un terremoto, una cometa ed è apparso un serpente
nel cielo. Non dice, va detto a onore di Sigeberto e di Jean Blu, non dice, e tutti
hanno avuto paura della fine del mondo. Lui si limita a accumulare questi prodigi. E lui
stesso è un millenarista. L'anno 1000 è passato, però l'impressione di quella cifra tonda
continua a funzionare. Passano altri 70 anni, 1170 circa. Un altro cronista, Cister Cense,
Guillaume Godel, che ha letto anche lui i cronisti dell'anno 1000 e degli anni successivi,
ha scoperto che nell'anno 1010 c'erano state delle visioni, carestia, eclissi. Ce n'è
abbastanza. Guillaume Godel scrive, nell'anno 1010 ci sono stati tutti questi prodigi e molta
gente ha avuto paura che il mondo finisse. Nelle sue fonti non c'era questo. Quelli che
erano vissuti nel 1010 gli hanno detto c'è stata l'eclisse. Ma Guillaume Godel non è
mica uno sciocco, lo sa cosa pensa la gente quando vede l'eclisse. E allora ecco il primo
che parla di un terrore collettivo. Peccato per noi che lo mette nel 1010. È esasperante,
ma è così. Dopodiché il Medioevo continua. Lungo tutta questa epoca che gli amici di Carducci
immaginavano come epoca di credulità e ignoranza, non c'è più nessun altro che si sogni di riprendere
questa frasetta sui terrori. Poi finalmente arriva il Rinascimento. In quell'epoca illuminata
che è il Rinascimento cominciano a saltare fuori storici che invece ci credono che la
gente avesse avuto paura della fine del mondo. Salta fuori per esempio il Tritemio, che pochi
di noi giustamente hanno sentito nominare, ma che è un importante umanista tedesco, inizio
del Cinquecento, che nella sua cronaca anche lui ha letto Sigeberto di Jean Blu. E anche
lui quindi dice che nell'anno 1000 ci fu il terremoto e ci fu la cometa e ci furono le
visioni. E molti si spaventarono temendo che arrivasse l'ultimo giorno. Questo non l'ha
letto in Sigeberto di Jean Blu. Ma voi capite come funziona? È un umanista. Ormai è il
Rinascimento. Quei poveracci là stavano nelle tenebre del Medioevo. Quando hanno visto
tutti quei prodigi? Figurati se non si sono spaventati. Si sono spaventati e come? E il
Tritemio lo scrive. E continua così. Autori su autori riprendono questa chiacchiera e ognuno
ci ricama sopra. Perché è bello immaginarsela questa scena di tutto un mondo che si ferma
per il terrore. E mi rendo conto che a dirlo così sembra incredibile, perché noi abbiamo
questa ostinata convinzione che quando leggiamo qualcosa è perché l'autore la sa quella cosa
che scrive e quindi è vera. E non è assolutamente così. Si possono scrivere le cose più stupefacenti
e magari l'autore se ne convince anche, ma se gli vai a chiedere come fa, vabbè lasciamo
stare perché qui prenderei una via. Ma comunque diventa un luogo comune. Tutti sanno nel
600, nel 700, nell'800 che ci sono stati i terrori dell'anno 1000. Va detto che c'è un
motivo che li incoraggia in questa credenza e che noi possiamo anche capirli, poveretti,
perché in realtà, specialmente nel 700, nel 700 comincia una storiografia scientifica,
moderna. Si comincia a rifare la storia del passato non solo copiando i vecchi cronisti,
ma confrontando i documenti. Nel 700 comincia anche la storia delle nazioni moderne, delle
letterature moderne. Ora, le nazioni moderne sono nate nel Medioevo, le letterature nostre
sono nate nel Medioevo, ma prima o dopo l'anno 1000? Dopo l'anno 1000, evidentemente. Tutti
abbiamo studiato a scuola la storia della letteratura italiana, no? E comincia tutto
dopo l'anno 1000. Prima niente. E allora i primi studiosi, i primi eruditi che si mettono
a fare queste grandi storie d'insieme, scoprono che il Medioevo, fin grosso modo all'anno
1000, è un'epoca che ha lasciato poche testimonianze, succedono poche cose, dopo invece esplode
tutto. La letteratura provenzale, quella francese in lingua d'oile, poi quella italiana, i trovatori,
tutto. Le grandi cattedrali, una grande civiltà che nasce dopo l'anno 1000. Ora, tutti
questi eruditi e questi studiosi sanno che nell'anno 1000 il mondo si era fermato per
il terrore. E allora è facilissimo dare quel colpetto che aggiusta tutto. L'anno 1000 diventa
il punto di partenza, perché è chiaro che fino all'anno 1000 la gente era troppo terrorizzata
per fare qualcosa. E dopo invece si sono messi in movimento. Sembra una barzelletta dirlo
così. È stato sostenuto molto seriamente. Vi cito un libro importantissimo nella storia
della cultura italiana. L'abate Bettinelli, che alla fine del Settecento pubblica una prima
grande storia della letteratura e della cultura italiana. Bettinelli non è uno qualunque,
il suo libro è un libro importantissimo, come dire, preveggente addirittura. Basti dire
che il libro del Bettinelli, uscito nel 1773, si intitola Risorgimento d'Italia. Negli studi,
nelle arti e nei costumi, dopo il 1000. E di conseguenza con cosa comincia il libro del
Bettinelli? Comincia raccontando com'è che per fortuna il mondo si era immesso in movimento.
E in particolare l'Italia, che aveva tante belle cose da fare, ma fino all'anno 1000 nessuno
si muoveva. Dopo il 1000 tornossi alquanto alle arti, che erano prima state neglette per
una credenza universale che la fine del X secolo dovesse essere ancora quella del mondo.
Notate che il Bettinelli, curiosissimo, sgrida gli storici, perché dice che gli storici ne
parlano poco di questa faccenda. E che invece è importantissima, dice il Bettinelli, perché
è chiaro che quelle paure impedivano che nascesse la letteratura italiana, che è quello che
interessa a lui e tutto il resto. Quell'opinione, che stesse per finire il mondo, non è credibile
quanto pregiudicasse in sino all'ultimo giorno del secolo X. E non è credibile quanto danno
togliesse, cioè quanto bene abbia fatto, il non aspettato principio del 1000. L'orror
sempre presente di una prossima desolazione universale tolse ad ognuno speranze. Questa
orrenda disperazione, non dovette lasciare altri pensieri, eccetera, eccetera, eccetera,
e via romanticheggiando. Poi sorge il sole dell'anno 1000. Ma l'abbiamo già sentita questa
storia? E Carducci, ho cominciato con quello. Questo che sto leggendo adesso è Bettinelli,
un secolo prima. Ma anche Carducci, ricordate in che occasione scrive queste cose? Io l'ho
detto prima, ma voi non ve lo ricordate. Nel suo primo discorso sullo svolgimento della
letteratura nazionale. In altre parole c'è un filo diretto preciso. Chi nel 700 e nell'800
vuole fare la storia della grandezza italiana, della civiltà italiana, prima del 1000 non
trova niente e di conseguenza parte dai terrori. E quello che succede in Italia succede in Francia,
succede negli altri paesi, ognuno per conto suo. Bene, siamo a buon punto, direi. C'è
ancora un aspetto che io vorrei sottolineare di questa faccenda e che la rende forse in
qualche misura un po' più attuale rispetto, come dire, a tutti questi discorsi di monaci
del XII secolo che vi ho inflitto. Nell'800 sono tutti così convinti dei terrori dell'anno
1000 anche perché nell'800 si stanno combattendo delle battaglie ideologiche molto precise.
Carducci, che abbiamo visto è uno dei principali autori di questa leggenda, o uno di quelli
che l'hanno espressa nel modo più romantico, più evocativo, beh Carducci è anche quello
dell'inno a Satana, naturalmente. È il Carducci delle invettive contro il Vaticano, contro
la Chiesa del suo tempo, reazionaria, nemica del progresso. È il Carducci delle poesie
che attaccano il gran prete che in Vaticano continua a fare il re e a tagliare le teste
degli oppositori. Nell'800 si combatte, fra tante battaglie che si combattono, si combatte
anche una battaglia della cultura laica, progressista, scientifica, positivista, contro la superstizione.
E la Chiesa dell'800 è vista da molti di questi che si battono per una cultura laica
e progressista è vista come un nemico. Non a caso va detto, qui mi permetto una piccola
parentesi perché le cose vanno contestualizzate, se c'è un anticlericalismo così violento
nell'800 è anche naturalmente perché la Chiesa di allora fa di tutto per farsi considerare
come un nemico, perché la Chiesa di allora è spaventata dal progresso. Sono cose che si
possono dire tranquillamente perché la Chiesa di oggi lo ha riconosciuto ampiamente. La Chiesa
dell'800 è terrorizzata dal progresso, è terrorizzata dal liberalismo, è terrorizzata
dalla scienza, combatte il modernismo in tutte le sue forme, scomunica, chiude porte. È
chiaro che dall'altra parte la Chiesa è vista come il nemico oscurantista. Allora, se la Chiesa
e la religione cristiana sono fonte di superstizioni e di ignoranza, ancor più sarà successo così
in quella brutta, lontana epoca da cui per fortuna siamo usciti, in cui la Chiesa dominava
il mondo, il Medioevo. Nel Medioevo certamente la Chiesa, così ragionano Carducci e tanti altri
e i Michelet in Francia, regnavano davvero le tenebre. E allora non c'è da stupirsi se
la gente era così ignorante, se la gente era in preda a tutte le paure, se all'arrivo
dell'anno 1000 il mondo si è fermato per il terrore. Ma se da una parte c'è chi combatte
questa battaglia, anche dall'altra c'è chi combatte, anche dal campo ecclesiastico c'è
chi studia e scrive e pubblica per dire che non è vero niente, che la Chiesa non era
affatto, come dire, fautrice di ignoranza e superstizione, anzi, la Chiesa faceva tutt'altro.
E allora i primi che dicono, ma questi terrori dell'anno 1000, di cui siete tutti così sicuri,
ma è poi vero, scusate, che ci sono stati. Vogliamo andare a controllare, vedere i cronisti
di quegli anni cosa scrivevano, cioè in sostanza fare un po' quello che io ho fatto stasera.
I primi che fanno queste cose non sono spinti semplicemente, non sono studiosi spinti dall'amore
della verità, ma sono anche combattenti di una guerra. Il primo articolo che esce nel
1873, che parla, in Francia, dei pretesi terrori dell'anno 1000, è di un prete, uno
studioso, ecclesiastico, Don Plain, per cui dimostrare che i terrori dell'anno 1000 non
ci sono mai stati non è soltanto un punto di precisazione storica, ma vuol dire dimostrare
che hanno torto i laici, gli scienziati, i positivisti a parlare della Chiesa come di
un fautore appunto della tenebra e dell'ignoranza. Non è vero niente. E qui devo anche confessare
che è molto imbarazzante questa faccenda, per me. Perché io devo dire, ho già detto
un po' prima e lo dico di nuovo, che tutto sommato sui due piatti della bilancia, allora,
nelle condizioni di allora avevano ragione i mangiapreti e aveva torto la Chiesa. La Chiesa
stava davvero combattendo delle battaglie sbagliate contro tutto ciò che c'era di moderno,
il liberalismo, la democrazia, l'unità d'Italia, ogni sorta di cose. Avevano ragione quegli
altri, per me. Però quegli altri che avevano ragione, per dimostrare che avevano ragione,
hanno costruito, hanno fatto una cattiva storiografia. Hanno costruito una leggenda
e ci hanno creduto. I preti di Pio IX, che difendevano il Vaticano forse più oscurantista
e reazionario che ci sia stato negli ultimi secoli, però avevano ragione e hanno fatto
una storiografia giusta e sono andati a scoprire la verità. L'ultimissima cosa che vorrei dirvi,
che prosegue questo discorso e lo attualizza ancora di più, è che sembrerà strano, ma
non è ancora del tutto finita. E cioè c'è ancora, almeno in Francia, che è un paese
dove le spaccature ideologiche sono un po' diverse dalle nostre, ma sono profonde, specialmente
quella fra cultura laica della Repubblica e cultura cattolica. C'è ancora oggi una qualche
dimensione di attualità in questa polemica sui terrori dell'anno 1000. E mi spiego.
E' uscito da pochissimo tempo un libro che fin dal titolo è chiaramente programmatico.
I falsi terrori dell'anno 1000. E' di uno studioso molto famoso in Francia, non ancora in Italia,
che si chiama Sylvain Guggenheim, come la Peggy Guggenheim dell'arte contemporanea, sarà
quindi anche lui di origine ebraica, verosimilmente, ma è uno studioso cattolico, che ha scritto
questo libro molto militante, I falsi terrori dell'anno 1000, dicendo in sostanza questo.
E' vero che i terrori dell'anno 1000 non ci sono stati, ormai lo sanno tutti. Ma non basta,
bisogna dissiparla di più questa leggenda. Perché se andiamo a vedere la storiografia
del Novecento, la grande storiografia francese, Duby, quegli studiosi, quando si sono occupati
dell'anno 1000, dice Guggenheim, certo hanno ammesso che i terrori sono una leggenda, ma hanno
molto insistito sul fatto che comunque c'era il millenarismo, c'erano questi movimenti, c'era
un'atmosfera pesante, di inquietudine. In sostanza Guggenheim, attaccando alcuni mostri
sacri della storiografia del Novecento, come appunto Georges Duby, Guggenheim dice, questi
in realtà, grandi maestri per carità, però hanno creato di nuovo un'impressione falsa,
sono tornati a dare questa impressione dell'anno 1000 come epoca tenebrosa, inquieta, oscura.
Mentre dice Guggenheim, non è vero niente. Perché è interessante scoprire questo? Perché
Guggenheim, come vi dicevo, è uno studioso non solo cattolico, ma arci cattolico, ultra,
che è diventato famoso in Francia, non per questo libro sui terrori dell'anno 1000. Guggenheim
è diventato famoso in Francia per un libro che è uscito cinque anni fa, che si intitola
Aristotele al Mont Saint Michel. Il Mont Saint Michel l'avete presente, è la famosa
Abbazia in Normandia, quella che sta in mezzo al mare quando c'è la marea rimane isolata
dalla terraferma. Guggenheim, in Aristotele al Mont Saint Michel, sostiene, e dico sostiene
perché il suo libro ha provocato polemiche furibonde con illustri studiosi che hanno detto
che è tutta spazzatura e altri illustri studiosi che hanno detto che invece è molto interessante.
quindi io non l'ho ancora letto, vi riferisco soltanto quel che so in sintesi. Guggenheim,
in questo libro, sostiene di aver scoperto che nel monastero del Mont Saint Michel, nel
Medioevo, c'era un grande centro di traduzione dal greco in latino e lì si traduceva direttamente
dal greco in latino Aristotele e Tolomeo, gli scienziati greci e così via. Io credo che voi
capiate già le implicazioni di questo, ma Guggenheim, per non farsi mancare niente,
le esplicita nel suo libro. Queste pagine le ho viste, sono andato a vederle. Guggenheim
dice, e quindi non è vero quello che ci hanno sempre raccontato, che è grazie agli arabi
che noi abbiamo potuto possedere la filosofia e la scienza greca. La filosofia e la scienza
greca, dice Guggenheim, noi cristiani ce le siamo tradotte direttamente dal greco e non
avevamo nessun bisogno degli arabi. E tanto per essere ancora più chiaro, nelle ultime
pagine del libro Guggenheim dice, e del resto si sa, che l'arabo è una lingua completamente
inadatta per parlare di argomenti scientifici, che gli arabi come mentalità non sono un popolo
di scienziati e di conseguenza era ridicolo pensare che noi gli dovessimo qualche cosa.
Alla cultura islamica medievale noi non dobbiamo niente. Voi capite che è un argomento
un filino provocatorio. E di fatti in Francia ci sono stati dibattiti furibondi su questo
libro. Ora capite? Colpisce che lo stesso studioso che scrive Aristotele al Mont Saint-Michel,
il libro successivo che scrive è per dire, ricordiamocelo che il terrore dell'anno mila
non ci sono mai stati. Perché qui i laici hanno di nuovo un po' confuso le idee. Si
parla troppo di millenarismo medievale, invece non è vero niente. Io qui non mi schiero,
i terrore non ci sono mai stati, questo è evidente, chiarissimo, ma quello che mi interessava
far vedere in conclusione è come sono complesse le vie con cui si creano i miti e con cui poi
rimangono radicati. Magari si creano in modo del tutto innocente uno che ha aggiunto una
righina in una cronaca e magari rimangono lì silenziosi per secoli. Poi viene il momento
in cui una certa cosa torna utile nelle battaglie di quel momento e allora la si tira fuori e
lo spirito critico sparisce. È un meccanismo estremamente impressionante. Per chi di voi ci
sarà anche domani e dopodomani, racconteremo esempi credo più divertenti di questo, se Dio
vuole, di casi simili. Questo era il primo, questo avevo da raccontarvi stasera e quindi
qui mi fermo. Grazie.
Grazie.